as everyone in here has always been the
staunchest of Republicans how are you
going to celebrate how are you guys how
are you going to celebrate when your
favorite political party wins Supreme
control over the government in a week
you're just trying to trigger me right
now trigger you no one I I don't like
you're not even American Serge are you
Republican no that no one in this room
has has been a traditional Republican no
and here we are being like Oh it's
better they win I guess yeah yeah I mean
we can acknowledge the Republican party
is mostly trash but we don't want the
Democrats to win when it comes to this I
don't even know who the Democrats are
that are running so to be honest I vote
for people I don't vote for political
parties if the people are better but
they have it on their shirt I will not
vote for John I would not Advocate
voting for John Federman because he just
suffered a stroke he's not in a healthy
mind state right now I'm not a huge fan
of Dr Oz politically but he seemed
cogent he's more cogent than fetterman
at least you know yeah yeah for
Republicans today or just for Democrats
uh 10 years ago
literally yeah we're just getting a
little time there before they fully
Implement all the agenda